Hey guys, it's rob i hope you're all doing well.
I've been gone for a bit i know but i'm back now.
I got some new equipment, I cut my own hair
and i'm ready to make some videos. Now while
some people said that the ninja star boomerang
was fake, it doesn't work, or it just isn't fun
to play with my new kitten Suki is a professional
at it. As you can see and she absolutely loves to
play with it. In all seriousness though, I do want
everyone to be able to fold it and also to enjoy
it and have it return to them. So today, I'm going
to introduce the Ultra-Lite Ninja Star Boomerang!
It uses a lot less paper: two one eighth strips of
printer paper so it's a little bit easier lighter
and simpler to fold and interlock. Not only that
but with one sheet of printer paper you can make
four Ultra-Lite Ninja Star Boomerangs. Even though
it flies in a little bit of a smaller circle,
it comes back super fast and it's easy to
catch. If you saw my origami convention video,
you'll see that with practice I got just about
everyone to fold and catch their boomerangs.
If you use the right paper and you practice
throwing and folding it, you'll be a pro in
no time and it will come back to you. I'll explain
the paper you need and also some troubleshooting
tips towards the end so without further ado let's
get folding the Ultra-Lite Ninja Star Boomerang.
I'm using bright letter sized paper with a GSM
of 89, which tells you how thick the paper is,
but pretty much any eight and a half by 11
letter sized or A4 proportion paper will work
fine. Just note the weight on the package or
cover. I found a GSM or thickness of the paper
between 75 to 100 works the best. Anything below
or above that may be too flimsy or heavy and not
fly properly. We'll have to get the paper's width
into eighths like these strips which means we'll
have to cut the paper in half three separate
times. If you'd like two different colors,
then you'll have to do it with two sheets.
Hold the paper so that the longer edges are
horizontal and fold it in half lengthwise. You
can use scissors, or if you're good at tearing,
you can do that. I like to first press in the
middle and slowly line up the paper to the
right and left before I make the final crease.
We can finally fold the paper in half one last
time and then tear it. When you've done that
three times your paper will look like this.
For the second piece you can keep the other half
you just tore away or use a different color.
Let's take the left side and fold it across to
the right side. Hold it so that the edges are
aligned and just crease it on the left side by
just running your fingernail against it. You can
open it up so that it looks like a little mountain
and set it down on the table. The right edge is
going to go down into this vertical line so just
line it up and then give it a crease on the right
side here. Now we can take the left side and fold
it up onto that vertical line also making a crease
on the outside here.Then we can flip it over just
give it a quick press to flatten it out. You'll
notice there's a horizontal crease here. Lift up
the right side so that it is even on the bottom
with the left side as you could see here. Now, I'm
just going to take my fingers here my two pointers
and pinch it in the middle and set it down on
the table. I'm going to lift the bottom edge
to the top but i'm going to leave a little bit of
space. As you'll see from here to there it's about
three to four millimeters. Then you can just pinch
it in the middle with your two fingers like that
and just press down gently in the middle
making a little pinch in the paper like this.
Now that we've marked the distance in the
middle we have to make sure that the edge
is the same distance and parallel to the top
one all throughout so i'm just going to bring
it up a little closer here because i want it to be
three to four millimeters then I can crease it all
throughout the right and do the same with the left
side making sure that this edge here on the bottom
aligns with the top one equally. Then you can
just run your fingernail against the bottom edge
just to ensure that it's really sharp and easy
to fold being careful not to pull it apart.
I'm going to lift up the middle portion
and the bottom edges that we just folded in
unfold the right side and you'll see that we now
have two new creases in the paper here you see
there's one here and the other here on the top
one we can actually just take that edge and fold
it down because it's in the right direction but
this one is a mountain fold and we need to flip
it so just simply set it down on the table and put
your nail directly in it and kind of press on it
you can also lift up the paper and kind of look
at the crease so you can press on the opposite
ends and just flatten everything out you'll
notice the bottom right edge was lifted up
and the top left edge was lifted down so that
they're now overhanging as you could see here
there should be a gap of about three to
four millimeters like i said previously
flip it over set it down and we can move on now
you've got past the hard part so we can just
unfold these edges that we just folded in and
we're going to airplane fold both of the corners
here into the midline the right triangle that
you see should be bigger than the left one once
you've completed that then you can do the same on
the other side and we're going to fold the edges
back down so that we have the overlaps and flatten
everything out now we can just lift both sides at
the little corner that we have near the diamond
in the middle and we're ready to make another one
now that we have two pieces fold them up slightly
at the corner near the center diamond where i've
drawn the line and place the one on the right
perpendicular over the left one we can then
fold the top arm of the boomerang down and go in
a clockwise direction proceed to fold the second
and then the third you'll notice because of the
overlap it will not fit perfectly and this is okay
just proceed to slightly untucked the first one
and bend the last one so that you can tuck it
underneath the first now that it's tucked in
we need to make sure that the middle is tight
so pull on the opposite arms gently
and make sure that they're folded
all the way up to that corner press down
firmly in the middle and flatten everything out
we can now fold that overlap or airfoil down
so it's laying on top the other edge as flat
as possible so fold it down along the edge all
the way to the center just like that if it rips
slightly at the center it's usually okay but just
try and be gentle and it should look like this
fold them all down along the other edge and crease
them sharply once we finished folding all four of
the airfoils or flaps down we can flip it over and
we're going to flatten it down with our fingernail
and sharpen the ends this is necessary to
help it spin and fly once you've finished
all this you've done the ultralight ninja star
boomerang and you're ready to do a test flight
to throw it first inspect it and make sure it's
neat flat and that there are no major bends
also hold it so the four interlock squares
are facing the left grab it between your
right pointer and middle finger on the end of
an arm and the rest of it should be facing your
body curl your wrist and we're going to throw
it slightly out slanting to the left like this
okay so it went to the left let's try that again
okay so the boomerang works well just make sure
you're flicking your wrist at the correct speed
and not holding on to the boomerang
for too long or it can go to the ground
or spin off to the left it needs to spin sideways
at an angle like a frisbee so you need to get that
curved wrist action going if it goes to the left
more than once try adjust it by bending the arms
away from the square side just like this then try
throwing it once again and it should fly better
sookie i hope you guys enjoyed the
video for the ultralight ninja star
boomerang if you did be sure to give
it a thumbs up down below and click
that notification and subscribe
button if you haven't already
i'm trying to come out with more videos um i know
it takes me a while and that's because i've been
trying i've been trying to make more original
videos meaning i've been trying to design my
own things and that takes time uh but it shouldn't
take that long i i'd also like to expand and try
different things i was thinking another rubik's
cube video i was thinking other cool paper stuff
maybe quick things like other paper footballs and
stuff like that i also did a live zoom session
where i taught a couple different things happy
birthday frankie i think that there might be other
people who might want to perhaps do that and if
i set up like a patreon or something where we can
communicate and maybe do live sessions i bought
some new equipment uh i'm working on my my editing
technique to make it easier for me because when i
do teach it sometimes i i talk during the teaching
and that makes it 10 times harder because if i
mess up i wind up having to start all over again
so it takes so long so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to concentrate more on the
filming aspect and then just just double over
it later and explain it really well that way
see if you like it so if you did like the
different angles in the video uh let me know
give me a comment down below and let me know if
you have any ideas for something you'd like to
see in the future all right guys i gotta take
a nap and rest my back so i'll see you soon
i hope you guys enjoyed the video